non mais quelle hypocrisie encore une
fois on a un gars c'est un délit et tout
franchement tu nous fais chier là tu
nous fais passer pour des branquignols
tu veux passer pour des branches encore
une fois la politique justement toute la
place Paris les politiques sont
complètement déconnecter de leur
concitoyens cette Coupe du Monde quoi
qu'il arrive elle va avoir lieu quoi
qu'il arrive les gens qui l'a regardé ça
sert à rien à part faire un coup de com
à quoi ça sert bien sûr les Français il
y a pas longtemps qu'il disait que 30 %
des gens soient dix ans allez boycoter
la Coupe du monde j'aimerais bien voir
les audiences à mon avis ça va cartonner
donc c'est de l'hypocrisie ça sert à
rien par faire
hypocrisie c'est un coup de conne de
bafouer les droits de l'homme c'est un
coup de gueule
ce qu'on dit c'est qu'il y a une immense
tartuffie c'est-à-dire que c'est pas
d'hier tu vois
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas d'hier de
d'avant-hier qu'on s'est rendu compte
que la Coupe du monde était attribuée au
Qatar d'accord on a entendu personne
quand on vend au Qatar on entend
personne quand on vend sur le
gouvernement vend au Qatar on en parle
6000 ouvriers qui sont morts on a
entendu pendant la construction les
constructions du stade on a entendu
merci
en Chine tu as entendu quelqu'un quand
il y a eu les JO en Russie tu as entendu
on s'y prend peut-être trop tard mais il
est jamais trop tard il a dénoncé
là tu sanctionnes les joueurs mais pas
de bêtises
qui est la plus intéressante Mathieu tu
as rien à dire quand il y a la F1 ou 4
parts au Bahreïn nous émirates
c'est hyper hypocrite et d'ailleurs et
d'ailleurs la peur
nationale veut absolument qu'on ne
boycotte pas exactement bravo ils
veulent absolument qu'on ne boycotte pas
parce que justement eux ils ont dénoncé
des choses ils disent que ça peut
avancer petit à petit et si on se bouche
les yeux on ferme les oreilles à ce
moment-là il y a plus de lanceur
d'alerte allez voir là-bas tout le monde
sait emparé du sujet
alors il y a tout le monde le Mélenchon
il est pour le boycott hein Jean-Luc
Mélenchon voilà il y a Daniel
riolote et des imbéciles mais juste il
se réveille trop tard il va te faire
voir pour moi ils veulent faire du buzz
Jean-Luc c'est le roi du buzz arrête je
connais bien assez bien j'aurais dû
Mélenchon il s'est dit là il y a un buzz
à faire avec le Qatar je vais y aller je
le connais par cœur là il y en a un même
il y a Vincent Lindon
lui tiens il s'est réveillé c'est des
années que j'avais pas vu celui-ci
à proposer
non non donc du coup c'était intéressant
parce que lui il a dit que il fallait
absolument pas y aller s'il y avait au
moins un joueur de foot un peu
charismatique un peu courageux il
fallait absolument que les joueurs de
football côte et bah lui il était
président du dernier festival de Cannes
personne ne vous écoute
Festival de Cannes le dernier festival
de Cannes il y a le dos institut qui a
financé 10 films en compétitions
il s'occupe plus de de critiquer Charles
Aznavour des dîners
dans l'économie française le Qatar il
nous fournit du gaz là on entend
personne et là on se réveille par
opportunisme alors on est même Castaldi
en gaz mais oui la Coupe du monde ça va
être ça va être une grande fête
populaire une grande fête populaire qui
aurait pu venir les gens regardez les
matchs et on les en prive uniquement
politique votre argument c'est de dire
avant on disait rien alors
il fallait le dire
pas de conneries dans ce cas là il
fallait pas qu'il leur donne dans ce
c'est ça c'est comme si moi tu vas me
donner un jouet et je vais jouer toute
la journée et je vais te faire chier bah
tu me dis bah je vais te le reprendre
enfin c'est un mauvais exemple
climatisé cette hypocrisie parce que il
y a eu cette courbe on disait c'est
dramatique il y a 500 morts c'est
dramatique qui a 1000 morts personne n'a
bougé c'est dramatique
c'est dramatique on en est à 3000 morts
tout le monde s'en foutait tout le monde
en avait rien à [ __ ] c'est dramatique
qui a 5000 morts tout le monde s'en
foutait et là il nous sorte l'argument
il y a 6000 morts ils sont pas mis en un
jour les 6000 morts
ça sera ton dernier mot de toutes les
missions il y a encore un an après
il y a encore un an toutes les chaînes
TF1 tout ça et moi je producteur il
m'appelait pour dire faites des trucs
sur Dubaï vendait le Qatar vendez les
Emirats à fond à fond à fond mentalement
et toi aussi non pas du tout
non c'est vrai vous avez pas validé vous
avez des suggère-t-on mais en tout cas
voilà et c'était fallait pousser pousser
pousser à mort maintenant la c'est au
contraire plus rien plus rien sur les
Emirats plus rien sur le Qatar Abu Dhabi
plus rien sur tout ça justement parce
que ça y est alors ok on sonne de rendu
compte avec un an de retard mais ça y
est tout le monde prend conscience qu'il
faut arrêter maintenant de soutenir et
de vendre alors attends attends mais moi
je trouve que là tu abuses là je vais
dire bien sûr tous les emplois créés tu
fais quoi on fait quoi
avec le PSG et là il a été bien sympa